in wuppertal plant die stadt seit jahren
die sanierung der else lasker-schüler
gesamtschule und des johannes rau
gymnasiums die schulen sollten nach und
nach in ein ausweichquartier aus
containern ziehen
verantwortlich dafür ist das
gebäudemanagement der stadt aber die
vorgeschriebene baugenehmigung für den
container schulbau wurde vergessen
deshalb müssen die sanierungen auf
unbestimmte zeit verschoben werden
die planung der stadt wuppertal ist an
dieser stelle scheiße gelaufen und es
ist eine reine katastrophe
das ist nicht die erste verschiebung wir
warten seit jahren ich bin jetzt der
abschlussjahrgang und war damals die
unterstufe und da hieß es schauen wir
werden saniert und es geht gut los und
wir stehen wieder da und müssen mit den
schultern zucken
das finde ich unerträglich
in dieses gebäude in wuppertal sollten
die beiden schulen während der
sanierungsarbeiten ausweichen 2018 kommt
es hier jedoch zu einem schweren
wassereinbruch deshalb beschließt die
stadt den abriss als ersatz soll hier
eine schule aus containern gebaut werden
vor wenigen wochen kommt plötzlich die
rolle rückwärts das gebäudemanagement
der stadt stoppt alle planungen der
grund für den bau der schulcontainer ist
eine baugenehmigung zwingend
erforderlich die wurde aber nie
beantragt die schulleiterinnen sind
fassungslos
da ist für uns natürlich hier an der
schule so eine welt zusammengebrochen
denn wir waren vorher schon ganz konkret
dabei zu überlegen was muss mit umziehen
was können wir entsorgen also ich denke
das ist eine planung gewesen die so
nebenbei gemacht wurden ist und da hat
man sich nicht sehr viel mühe gegeben
wenn privatleute so handeln würden wären
sie schon pleite zu dem peinlichen
planungschaos möchte sich im wuppertaler
rathaus niemand vor der kamera äußern
schriftlich heißt es lapidar das risiko
bezüglich einer baurechtlichen
genehmigung der miet container wurde vom
gebäudemanagement wuppertal bmw
fälschlicherweise als gering
eingeschätzt
in den schulen haben sie angst dass gar
nichts mehr passieren wird
ja wissen überhaupt nicht wie jetzt die
alternativen aussehen also es ist alles
offen
das heißt wir sind nach fast fünf jahren
planung fangen wir jetzt im grunde
genommen wieder von vorne an
wir haben immer wieder zeit investiert
und das haben auch ganz viele lehrer
zeit investieren auch schüler zeit
investiert und das wird einfach nicht
gewürdigt
der wuppertaler stadtrat will im mai
entscheiden wie es weitergeht derzeit
kann niemand verlässlich sagen was es
unterm strich kosten wird und wann die
beiden schulen endlich saniert werden